no no
how are you greetings trembled with his
brief briefing for today wednesday
june 23 the metropolitan police
are investigating a homicide in the
northeast of the valley it happened at about 3
in the morning near the intersection between
newell's and lightning detectives
say that a  man stabbed
his ex's father to death the police arrived
and were able to arrest the man at this site
and so far the authorities have not
released the identities of those
involved there
will be several
coronavirus vaccination clinics around the
valley for this week today  for
example sharepoint high school will have one from 2:30
to 6 in the afternoon then tomorrow there
will be clinics available at the
fire station number 103 and
inside the trinity united church
starting at 8 in the morning also
for tomorrow and friday  there will be clinics in
the uars site junior high innobasque and
junior high for a complete list
you can enter our page and
inés neill dotcom diagonal in spanish
the white house launches two
new tools to help families collect
the child tax credit one of
these is to determine if families
qualify after answering some
questions online the other tool
is for families to decide  If you
want to collect this money monthly
or all at the same time at the time of
declaring your taxes next year
this is already available on
the there are hours page
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have a cloudy sky with some
chances of drizzle for today not
We will have temperatures in the
triple digits, however, the heat will
return on Friday and a weekend is expected
with temperatures
exceeding 100 degrees. Have a good day, I am
Héctor Mejía and this was your brief
information on Spanish ginseng
[Music]